Гучні кадрові перестановки у розпал війни.
В один вечір президент Володимир Зеленський своїми указами відсторонив від посади
генпрокурорку Ірину Венедіктову та усунув від виконання обов'язків голову СБУ Івана Баканова.
А наступного дня Верховна Рада підтримала їхнє звільнення.
Обоє раніше були близькими соратниками Зеленського, а Баканов - навіть другом дитинства президента.
Володимир Зеленський у своєму зверненні пояснив: серед працівників прокуратури й Служби безпеки
виявилося забагато зрадників і колаборантів.
За словами президента, уже зареєстровано 651 кримінальне провадження з цього приводу.
Понад 60 працівників органів прокуратури та Служби безпеки України залишилися на окупованій території
і працюють проти нашої держави.
Такий масив злочинів проти основ національної безпеки держави та звʼязки,
які зафіксовані між працівниками силових структур України та спецслужбами Росії,
ставлять дуже серйозні запитання до відповідних керівників.
Кожне з таких питань отримає належну відповідь.
Депутат від фракції "Голос", секретар парламентського комітету з нацбезпеки і полковник СБУ Роман Костенко
каже, що в нього вже давно були претензії до роботи Служби безпеки і до зрадників у лавах структури.
Ідеться зокрема про колишнього начальника головного управління внутрішньої безпеки СБУ,
бригадного генерала Наумова, який зробив блискавичну кар'єру в СБУ саме при Баканові
і втік з України 23 лютого - за день до початку російського вторгнення.
У мене були претензії, тому що я і прийшов у СБУ, щоб робити реформу.
Мене не влаштовує правоохоронний орган, який за показник ставить кількість кримінальних проваджень…
Хотів сказати "не завжди підслідних", а мабуть завжди непідслідних, у більшості своїй.
У нас були різні бачення реформи Служби безпеки.
Ну і плюс такі кадрові рішення типу Наумова, який по факту був сірим кардиналом і керував Службою безпеки,
і бачимо, чим це закінчилося - він втік з країни, з грошима десь його піймали.
Теж по цьому у мене було багато питань.
У своєму відеозверненні Зеленський також заявив, що очікує якнайшвидшого призначення
нового керівника Спеціалізованої антикорупційної прокуратури.
Очільника цього ключового для боротьби з корупцією відомства комісія не могла затвердити вже майже два роки.
Зробити це якнайшвидше неодноразово вимагали західні партнери України.
Нардеп від "Європейської солідарності" Микола Княжицький каже,
що відсторонення Венедіктової можуть ще більше затягнути призначення керівника САП.
Антикорупційного прокурора обрали, але призначити його може лише генеральний прокурор.
Тепер виникає питання - якщо генерального прокурора нібито немає, тому що Венедіктову відсторонено,
чи має вона повноваження призначати антикорупційного прокурора - ні, звісно.
Чи може його призначити виконувач її обов'язків?
Не може, тому що відповідно до чинного законодавства лише генеральний прокурор може призначити.
Заступник керівника офісу президента Андрій Смирнов у коментарі DW пояснив,
що такі кадрові рішення виявилися неминучими на тлі війни.
Щоправда, експертка антикорупційної організації Transparency International Катерина Риженко побоюється,
що надалі робота СБУ і прокуратури не зміниться на краще.
І що це лише ще раз підтвердило вже давні кадрові проблеми в команді Зеленського.
У нас взагалі в країні є певна проблема з професійними доброчесними кадрами в топменеджменті
як очільників основних державних органів, особливо, коли ми говоримо про сферу боротьби з корупцією, наприклад.
І таке відсторонення, і взагалі проблеми з очільниками важливих інституцій, на жаль, не є сюрпризом,
а є досить передбачуваною проблемою, яка отримала нову хвилю.
Антикорупціонерку непокоять особи, які тимчасово виконують обов'язки керівників структур.
Олексій Симоненко, який виконує обов'язки очільника офісу генпрокурора, відомий зокрема тим,
що підписав підозру Петру Порошенку у справі про держзраду у грудні торік.
Також його називають близькою особою до заступника глави Офісу президента Олега Татарова.
І Симоненка, і виконуючого обов'язки голови СБУ Василя Малюка журналісти "Української правди" у серпні 2021 року
зафільмували на святкуванні дня народження Олега Татарова.
Так, були і в громадськості, і в експертної спільноти запитання і до пана Баканова, і до пані Венедіктової,
але станом на зараз їхнє зняття не вирішує ці проблеми.
Тобто ми маємо замість пані Венедіктової, яку звинувачували у втручанні в антикорупційні справи, непрофесійності,
зараз ми маємо виконувачем обов'язків заступника пані Венедіктової,
до якого питань не менше, особливо враховуючи його роль у справі того ж Татарова,
передачі цієї справи від НАБУ і САП до СБУ, після чого справа щодо Татарова була зам'ята, закрита
і не закінчилась жодними рішеннями суду, яких очікувало і суспільство, і експерти.
В Офісі президента на прохання DW прокоментувати закиди про вплив Олега Татарова на правоохоронну систему відповіли таке:
Тим часом у Держдепартаменті США заявили, що стежать за кадровими перестановками в Україні,
але не припинятимуть ділитися розвідданими.
Експерти припускають, що звільнення з посад людей з близького оточення є вимушеним кроком Зеленського
під тиском не лише суспільних очікувань, але й західних партнерів.
І наголошують, що СБУ і прокуратура потребують  не виконувачів обов'язків,
а постійних очільників, адже безперебійна робота цих органів особливо важлива в часи війни.